so beantown is known for seafood
you know and clam chowder is like the
star of the city
obviously amongst the red sox hello
hello i know
um and today we're going to try a few
from three different boston
establishments and our favorite will be
awarded with the coveted
battle of the bites trophy this is huge
look at it i mean i've seen trophies in
my day i like
our trophies on this show they're really
fun this is great
i'm so excited thank you to everyone who
puts them together okay ross
you like shout out yeah yeah yes
yeah oh okay here's the deal i do i sort
of
you know as a kid you're like but then
your taste change so this is a big
moment for me
because they smell delicious i feel like
i'm gonna have a re like a reborn
with chowder today also the palette
changes like i thought capers were
disgusting and now that my palette's
dull and old i'm like bring on the
capers
you know it just it changes like things
i i don't know so
uh i'll be interested to see what the
mature ross palette says
okay also you're a real foodie yeah i do
i cook every single day so i would love
to have like
a reimagining of chowder so can we do it
now this is real
big time like real chowder and joining
us
um our three vfs for our taste test it's
annie ashley and scott hi
adrian hey guys hi okay and doing my
research on you i found out you're all
chowder fans so
i think that's really going to work for
this
i'm excited let's do this too okay
perfect
oh and of course our last judge is
social media fans that's right we put up
a twitter poll asking you to vote
for your favorite establishment and
we'll count the winner as one vote at
the end when we tally
let's get to eating okay all right we've
got three bowls of clam chowder in front
of us guys you ready
first one is from legal seafoods the
second one
is from boston sale loft and the third
is from yankee lobster company all right
as everyone's mouth-watering i'm
salivating
i'm trying to stay clam and carry on
okay first up let's take a look at uh
legal seafood
hello drew roger burke with some legal
seafoods here my grandfather had a
grocery store in the early 1900s and
then my
father opened a fish market up in 1950.
in 1968 we actually put together our
first restaurant we did have a chowder
at that time it was fish chowder
and you wouldn't believe the number of
complaints we used to get not that they
didn't like the fish chowder but they
thought that we should have a clam
chowder and so it took me about a year
and a half to sort of be happy with the
recipe
and then we introduced it and lo and
behold it outsold the fish chowder 40 to
1.
about 20 years ago we had a reporter
from the new york times come by
he said but it's your bra and therein
lies the secret we have an incredible
brock
this chowder has been served at every
presidential inaugural
since 1981. so i hope you'll agree
and say this is pretty darn good shower
he's doing it for this one
wow that's really important you don't
think a chowder is a party food all
right let's dig
in guys okay
oh my god um
hold on i've been sleeping on chowder
drew that's good
what do you guys think um like
okay ross thoughts okay i think it's
just perfectly balanced in terms of like
a flavor profile the salt is perfect
it's creamy and it just has that
hint of seafoodiness to it you know
annie
you have clam chowder at least once a
week but never from boston what do you
think
you know what i love it it's creamy it
has lots of clams
and uh the seasoning is just right it
doesn't need anything else
that's a really good point annie i
really appreciate that astute comment
all right we're going to move on to the
next contender
boston sailed off please to check it out
hi drew it's meredith tipping here at
the boston sail off to my family
restaurant
we first opened in 1984 and have
established ourselves as a staple for
fresh classic new england seafood
but none more so than our new england
clam chowder what makes our chowder so
different
is how rich and creamy it is and our not
so secret secret ingredient is the dill
as you can see the richness and
creaminess of the chowder really cuts
the earthiness of the dill
to make for an absolutely addictive
flavor nothing's better than having our
chowder sent to the spoon test
that's how rich and creamy it is in 2018
and 2019 we won the best of boston
magazine award for best chowder in the
city
in a city that's full of chowder options
ours is truly
unique thanks so much can't wait to
enjoy it
[Music]
all right let's try this i'm very
very excited it already looks so
different because of that
dill yes which is always fun i love
like when you're really judging on the
diversity of flavors
oh it's so different than the first one
oh it really is
okay yeah i really like it
i mean i think it's a pretty big deal
oh my god rossi i love you so much
ashley
let me ask you the last time you had
clam chowder was three years ago
what are your thoughts today all right
i'm
gonna take some words from you the
palette has changed i used to hate
dill and now dill is probably one of my
number one favorite seasonings so
as soon as i saw it in the jar i was
like i'm in
and i can attest that it holds up
to the clam powder standards that i used
to know
yeah it's so fresh and it pairs
perfectly with fish
and our last chowder comes to us from
yankee
lobster company please take a look
my name is frank zante i am third
generation and general manager of yankee
lobster company
the zante family has been fishing since
1921 and serving seafood since 1950.
now you can't be a seafood restaurant in
boston that does not have clam chowder
so we knew we were going to have to make
a wicked cooked chowder
we use celery onions potatoes and chop
clams
now the clams are from the atlantic
ocean so they are never frozen they are
always fresh
each bite will have tons of potatoes in
it and tons of clams
to give you a mouth-watering creamy new
england clam chowder we made over 2 500
gallons last year
and we are confident that we're going to
take home the trophy and now
it's time to eat enjoy
all right everybody rossie
annie ashley and scott shall we
let's eat okay let's see
okay now this one couldn't be more
different from the other two
okay this one has got an amazing
mirepoix
type of taste like onions and celery
and it's somehow extremely flavorful
feral but not so herbaceous way with raw
exactly
there's almost like a sweetness right
that makes it kind of addictive i want
to keep going back into it
it's very hearty it tastes like a meal
scott you've lived in boston before
and have tried many chowders what do you
think
that's right drew i lived in boston i
used to pass by yankee lobster
all the time i gotta say this is
a really great balance here it's chunky
but there's a really great balance
between the clams
and the vegetables the onions and the
celery i think it really brings the soup
together
yeah it's very stew-like and reminiscent
of like a holiday in a bowl
and i just want to say all the bffs you
should all be food reviewers you're
really good at this
i'm like appreciate that you're welcome
and like each distinct restaurant you
each brought a distinct
judgment to the table and i love that
and i thank you guys for that all right
it's time to vote but before we do
let's reveal who won our twitter poll we
asked all of you to vote on the favorite
of the three establishments and it was
tight
the winner checked the winning chowder
with 38.9 percent of the vote was
legal seafood
all right that's one for legal seafoods
and now it's our term one at a time
we're going to reveal our favorite
should we hold up our cards um i might
have given mine away
i'll start it off okay good i'm legal
seafood
um okay okay annie ash ross
okay well listen i actually liked all
three when i came in
not knowing if i like any but there was
one that i think was the perfect one
literally perfect i agree with you
i think there's nothing i would change
okay annie i like yankee
oh i see why totally that was it's so
good ashley
i gotta keep it real with the dill i'm
doing boston sale
i could have done that the palette has
spoken
scott i'm going boston's sail off as
well
i think it was really unique i liked it
so okay i guess the winner is legal
seafoods because ross i
and the twitch but barely
and any of them could have won um
by the way i'm not gonna lie um my uh
children's aunt joel cardman my very
very close uh friend
um it she sends me legal seafoods um on
gold belly as a gift to me like on a
constant regular basis
i love it and um i didn't know going
into this what this would be and i'm
happy that all these restaurants
participated with us we thank you all
for being a part of the show
you all have such wonderful incredible
soups we're so happy to celebrate you
today
thank you ross annie ashley scott thank
[Music]
you